Justin, Nic, congratulations.
You fellas are in the final
round of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history, a pair
of Frankish throwing axes.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, man.
Yeah, to you, man.
It feels great to be back home.
I have to make a pair of
Frankish throwing axes.
There's a lot of
subtle curves to them,
so it's going to be
a real challenge.
I'm going to take my
piece of mild steel.
I'm going to forge it out, and
then I'm going to fold it over
on itself, and then
I'm going to fit it
for a bit of high-carbon
steel in the middle.
I think that might work.
Mild steel doesn't like
to weld at the heats
that carbon steel does.
Hopefully she welds.
NIC: So I'm really excited.
We've made it to round three.
I'm ready to get sweating
and get some sparks
thrown on this thing.
So the plan today is I'm going
to take some 1018 mild steel.
We're going to start by drilling
two holes, go in with a drift,
chisel it out, and start forming
our eye on both of these.
It looks like a good
eye right there.
It's time to really
profile this thing,
so I'm taking it to
the power hammer.
That way they move
a whole lot easier.
So I have the
profile forged out.
I have the eyes drifted.
I'm feeling pretty
good about day one,
but we've got a whole
lot more work to do.
It's the morning of day
two, and I'm pretty tired.
Yesterday I was able to get both
my axes forge welded together.
Now I just got to finish
drawing them out today.
I want to get that
done to shape,
and it looks like it's staying--
oh, never mind.
It is not staying together.
I got a massive seam where that
forge weld was supposed to be.
The weld didn't take at
the very back of this.
So I'm going to try to
forge out this other head,
and almost right
away it split apart.
It's no good.
So don't like that.
Too [inaudible] to
even really forge
weld it again, so I
have to start over.
I don't know what these
tests are going to be,
but they're always brutal.
So I need to make them strong.
Hopefully they survive the test.
What I'm going to do is take
a piece of this mild steel,
and I'm going to
forge it out to shape
and then grind in a slot
for the high-carbon bit.
I really have to get
a good weld here.
I can't afford to
start all over again.
NIC: So it's day two.
The plan for the day is
to really fix those eyes
and really get them
to the shape I want.
Ended up stretching
way too much material.
One of the eyes
ended up cracking.
There's no saving these,
and I'm starting to panic.
I mean, I don't have a whole
lot of room right there.
At this point, I'm
burning daylight.
I'm just going to have to
scrap it and start over.
I'm going to do the wrap method.
Basically take a
flat bar of steel
and wrap it around
and eye and have
a carbon-steel core running
all the way through instead
of just a bit.
Don't really feel
good about it, but I'm
going to really power
through and work
as fast and hard as possible.
My forge welding went good.
I believe they're good
enough for heat treat.
And I feel like the
heat-treat process
went really well, so next
few days I can focus on
fit and finish.
JUSTIN: It's the
morning of day three.
I still got a little
more forging to do.
The steel's nice and hot.
Give it a couple whacks, and
it's feeling good already.
I'm, like, 99% sure I
have a good forge weld.
Go straight into the oil.
Oh yeah.
Our axes have to have a handle,
so I cut out the hickory.
Now it's time to shape them.
I can feel the sawdust
adhering to my cheeks.
NIC: So it's the
morning of day four.
Today I'm going
to play dress up.
These axes right now,
they're assembled.
Then I'm going to do
some finer detail work.
So they're both at the
finish that I want.
Now I need to go
above and beyond.
That's what my mom would
have wanted me to do.
This was a challenge,
and I'm really
proud that I pulled it off.
All right, bladesmiths.
Well, frankly, your Frankish
throwing axis look fantastic,
but are they lethal?
Well, to find that out,
I will take your weapons
and deliver some,
well, hellish of a blow
on this ballistics dummy.
Justin, you're up first.
You ready?
Sweaty to the teeth.
[music playing]
All right, Justin, every
chop can slash this deep.
Overall, sir, it'll kill.
Thank you.
All right, Nic,
it's your turn.
Ready to have fun?
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Nic,
upon impact, crushes
the face easily and the head.
Your edges, they dig in
with every chop and slash.
It will kill.
Thanks, Doug.
DOUG: Good job.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test.
I will be throwing
your Frankish throwing
axes into this large wall.
Justin, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Well, Justin, there is
a ding on this blade right
here where my finger is.
Your handles are comfortable.
The problem I have
with them, this bulb
is more fitted for a
fighting ax as retention.
A throwing ax, you kind
of want to let it go.
But, in all, your axes held up.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Nic, you're up.
You ready for this?
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Well, Nic, your
edges held up great.
I can't even tell that
they've been thrown.
Your handles show no damage.
Nice job.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is our sharpness test,
the foot-soldier attack.
This is all about what
the edges of your weapon
will do on the protective
clothing of this foot soldier.
Justin, you're up first.
You ready?
Yeah.
Kill it.
[music playing]
All right, Justin,
your edges over here,
as you can see on
the clothing on this,
it cuts right into
this foot soldier.
Overall, sir, your
weapons, it will cut.
Cool.
All right, Nic,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Play some good music.
[music playing]
All right, Nic, no glinting
or rolls on your edges.
Sharp with every cut
that went through.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
you guys have brought in some
high-quality, competitive,
and nicely matched Frankish
throwing axes, but only one of
you can be the "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Nic, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Justin, unfortunately your
Frankish throwing axes
did not make the cut.
Justin, both sets
of axes performed well
in all of our tests,
so this basically
came down to that
small amount of damage
you took in the strength
test and the overall design
of your axes.
Yes, sir.
Justin, you did a great
job, but at this time
I have to ask you to please
surrender your blades.
I just came here.
I did good.
I think I represented
myself well.
And I think, if nothing
else, these tests show that I
can make a working blade.
Nic, congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, man.
Please present your
axes to the judges.
This experience
was incredible.
I had so much fun.
I came here to win for my mom.
She was my biggest fan, and I've
done exactly what I plan to do.
Oh my gosh.
I did it, Mom.